folgt auf die internationale raumstation
iss eine mondstation gestern stellte der
deutsche astronaut alexander gerst seine
neue mission reisens auf der iss vor
zum ersten mal wird ein deutscher
astronaut dienst kommandant der
raumstation und gerd sprach über die
zukunft nach der station und war auf dem
mond wie konkret die pläne sind um das
gas während seiner mission plant jetzt
bei klink zum science fiktion herzlich
willkommen
der 2028 ist schluss sein kann
garantiert werden dass die module der
internationalen raumstation iss
funktionieren danach gibt es keine
garantie mehr dafür dass ich sicher
genug für die besatzung der heißt es
sind in zehn jahren werden also die
letzte abt verlauten und der letzte
astronauten verlassen
und wie wird über dem südpazifik zum
absturz gebracht alles was nicht dabei
verglüht wird ihn mehr versenden eines
der größten abenteuer der menschheit ist
damit beendet doch es soll weitergehen
das thematisierte der deutsche astronaut
alexander gerst gestern bei der
vorstellung seiner neuen isaf mission
2018 horizon gerst wird dabei ein halbes
jahr auf der station seien von april bis
oktober 2008 und drei monate während
dieser zeit wird er die raumstation
kommen wir im von mitte juli bis mitte
oktober wobei die wahl auf ihn fiel
nicht weil er eine besonders
führungsstarke persönlichkeit ist
sondern auch teamplayer menschen die
beide eigenschaften zusammen hätten
seien nämlich schwierig zu finden würde
im vorfeld wird er sich intensiv mit den
schwächen und stärken der anderen
astronautinnen und astronauten
beschäftigen und so in stresssituationen
die aufgaben optimal verteilen können
seine mission hat das viel experimente
fortzuführen und neue experimente zu
starten wird gab unter anderem mit bose
einstein kondensaten experimentieren wir
hatten ja bei pixum über das erste
dieser kondensate berichtet dass er vor
kurzem weltraum geschaffen wurde und
über eines mit negativer masse ein sehr
sehr sehr vielversprechendes
forschungsgebiet und der flug zum mars
und weitere aufenthalte auch auf dem
mond sollen vorbereitet werden
so wird kersten mit dem
fluoreszenzmikroskop zellen auf ihr
verhalten in der schwerelosigkeit
untersuchen
mit den experimenten o ton es wird in
sekundenschnelle der zustand der
muskulatur getestet und so das training
gegen muskel und knochenschwund in der
schwerelosigkeit weiter optimiert und
mit simons wird ein völlig neues device
getestet dass die arbeit von gas mit
künstliche intelligenz unterstützen soll
als 2001 im weltraum der kunden aber wie
dieses in zehn jahren nach der
zerstörung der als es weiter märz
verliert so klare vorstellungen er
berichtete gestern von den jungs leben
der esa wie will mit einem 3d drucker
wicklungen
dem mond bauen auf erst während der mond
der ideale außenposten der menschheit im
gegensatz zu eher losfahren können hier
viel einfacher beobachtungsstation
dauerhafte unterkünfte und auch
abwehrsysteme gegen astoria ii gebaut
werden und auch als startrampe für eine
mars-mission wäre der mond perfekt würde
ein raumschiff von dort zum mars starten
bräuchte es nur noch ein drittel des
staates gewicht des throns ja im
gegensatz hierzu hier auf der erde gab
es wird auf jeden fall auf dem mond
dabei sein sobald es ihr neues gibt
halte ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn er dazu kein video
verpassen wollt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und wenn er auf jeden fall jedes
video informiert werden wollen dann
vergessen ich den auch die glocken ja
hier geht es zu den best of videos von
links und ich sage bist dann bleibt dran